what do you think Neanderthals thought
of magnets and fire fire I know but
Magnus I don't know if they knew what a
magnum I except when they're spear got
stuck but even that you know they had
stone hello everyone this is extinction
week originally I had another plan for
this week and I guess I'm gonna do that
next week this week became the
extinction week simply because I got
confronted by a fella by name um guy
McPherson who peddles
that humans are at the end of the line
in this he agrees with me but the
problem is that he agrees for different
reasons and so we had a little debate
there primarily he was represented by
another fellow I think his name was Jax
and Davis and you can find the debate in
my extinction page on in Facebook okay
right now but you can look me up
extinction of man on Facebook you'll
find me for sure
and so you know that's where the whole
thing started I had to change my
schedule for this week because of that
because I wanted to address what these
people were saying and then yesterday I
covered a second part of it which is
mass extinctions how dinosaurs and other
animals disappeared I'm saying they
disappeared in like all mass extinctions
because of food and that it was
predictable that if you were standing at
the starting line of the Cambrian 542
million years ago you should be able to
predict and guarantee that some families
are plant orders of plants are gonna
disappear it's deterministic all plants
no plant lives forever but I'm not
talking about a plant and I'm not even
talking about a specie I'm saying even
orders of plants don't live forever
well orders are planted like families of
there are different categories that they
came up with yeah yeah there's a
different
different layers starting the animal
kingdom and then it goes on - yeah yeah
yeah and so but you know here we're
concerned primarily about plants and
animals of course there are other
categories I like to deal with plants
and animals because we often pretty much
relate to them and and so you know we
should be able to predict that plants
are periodically going to disappear
because because of a couple things first
they run their course their genetic
diversity decreases over time and that's
a long story people are not much aware
of but no no no that's just some too
long this is a recap no it's uh it's
that you know over time since these
plants are inbreeding you know they send
a pawn to each other and they interbreed
with in their their own species and
within their own orders and whatever
after millions of years you know this
this thing is wasted and and so these
plants at the last moment you know they
start having fewer varieties partly
because of the genetic problem the fact
that they lost their genetic diversity
over so many millions of years the
second problem is that there's a new
order of plants that have a new branch
something another group of plants have
branched out and created another more
advanced plants you know they just
adapted to a new environment maybe the
ferns replacing the like of pods the
club mosses and the horse tails club
mosses and horse tails were dominant in
the Carboniferous and we're talking
about 350 million years ago 300 million
years ago 50 years 50 years 50 million
years later these plants that cover the
entire you know the entire forest there
were a big trees 30 meters tall no no
the
is like Oh pots and you know they
leopard the leopard out and then drawn
there's one of these someplace that
exists in those days right and and as
well as the calamites very important as
far as the vegetation of those days and
who ate those young Vivian's or at least
the food chain was based on those who
ever ate them I don't know maybe it was
the insects the amphibians maybe eight
the insects but the point is that the
whole system relied on these plants
because there were no other plants and
that's important and and you can see
that amphibians are tied to like uh pods
in attitude young club mosses and
horsetails what comes next
you've got the mammal-like reptiles the
synapsids they come you know for the
next hundred million years what are they
they eat ferns primarily seed ferns and
they primarily grow of course otters
this is one of the plants that develops
towards the end of the Permian and by
252 million years ago the animals
disappear and so does glossopteris just
by coincidence they disappear at the
same time what replaces them they
cranium Triassic is Dyk rhodium era and
now you got your ARCA stars eating this
stuff that's another seed fern but it's
a different kind of seed firm so so it's
like these big categories of plant once
after is uh is is a big category there
are many Titan and many varieties of
glossopteris and glossopteris means
tongue you know from the Greek means
tongue because they had they named them
that way because they had tongue shaped
leaves and the point is that you know
these these plants died and in the
southern hemisphere Pangaea it was the
only plant yeah there were only two
acceptors that there was almost nothing
else so I can't imagine all these apps
just living and then and you know maybe
some fly some insect I don't know all
I'm saying is that the whole food chain
dependent on glossopteris at least
the southern hemisphere when they died
the animals died mass extinction what
came next not great you weren't real
quick oh the whole food chain collapse
what came next the arcus ours era you
also have some mammal-like reptiles that
cross over into the Triassic the
cynodonts right and a sign doesn't just
made it over the the line others
cynodonts die cynodonts died all of them
cynodonts continued they were there
called cynodonts because I know from
dogs they were doglike ok but they were
mammal-like reptiles they were synapses
they were a special category of animals
that don't exist anymore they crossed
over in the Triassic they died shortly
after a few million years after but
continued were the arcus ours what were
the arcus ours were crocodile like
animals what do they eat or what did
they their entire environment depend on
again seed ferns but a new type of scene
from the Dyke Roy combs and it says
another category of plant that's what
covered the landscape
what continued after that you got the
Jurassic that's a what 200 million years
ago now okay we're almost 50 every 50
million years every 100 million is
something new happens well what happened
then was the conifers took over the land
not that things just started they
existed for 100 million years before but
they were smaller plants they were not
the dominant plant the plants be
conifers became dominant in the Jurassic
let there be no doubt
Jurassic is known as the age of cycads
age of the Permian known as the end
Carboniferous a bird wrongly but those
are known as the age of ferns are marked
by the base of the food chain and the
animals that's how they do it what they
do the way of most of these markers the
geological markers most impedance in
mind most of the geological markers
our biggest on fish not happening in the
oceans because what happened in the
oceans they leave a lot of sediment and
so 11 and we're not talking about big
fish obviously we're talking about tiny
little mollusks and so on and there were
so many of them that you you see a full
layer in the rock and they so they look
look these these little animals you know
these could be for example what I call
these that go I need to see the I forget
the word the these tiny animals that
float in the sea
what did he call the plankton sometimes
you know you get a lot of plankton and
they say look all these plankton
disappeared at this point and then
another type of plankton continue and so
they base some of these layers based on
you know stuff like that it's not
necessarily on the big animals but of
course when they see the layer and
suddenly the big animals that dominated
the land disappear as well or some I
know amphibian that you know was half in
the water half half on man or whatever
he disappears you know it could be a big
one but in general it's done you know
with the tiny animals that's how they
determine all these layers and the point
is that after the Triassic what you have
is the extinction eventually of the
Archos ours what continues then are the
dinosaurs did God make the dinosaurs on
the last day when the arca stars died no
the dinosaurs were around you were like
the mammals when were when the dinosaurs
were around they were small they were
little guys they had to hide because
your Kassar would eat them when the ARCA
stars went away they were all crocodile
like animals that even crawled they
didn't live just on on in the sea they
they crawled on land they were the
dominant animals when they disappeared
who came next the dinosaurs and they
started growing they started getting big
and what on-site cats they didn't follow
the ferns they didn't follow the
the psychic counseling the psychos were
small correct correct
the seconds were no young they grew with
the psychic in other words is it's like
it's like these these periods coming
wave so yeah small small small then the
previous guys are dying off and as the
previous guys are dying off the small
guys that are next in line they go those
animals story plants herbivores and
carnivores grow in size while the other
guys are dying yeah men and they card
anisha's yeah they carve niches like
around what wall begins good everyone
looks on okay what can I open up yeah
carnivores so then food chain
essentially eats itself and as it's
eating itself the next guys in line come
up with us with a different food chain
yeah but it's like these waves of like
groups is waves of food chains it is
it's waves of food change that you have
new plants animals that the affords a
relationship with those plants and
herbivores and carnivores that forms a
relationship with those herbivores and
the whole chain eventually that
collapses and the parallel food team
continues of course we don't need some
of the insects out there I'm sure and
someone eats them there there's a fight
in in their little world
something something yeah well well
someone I mean some some other animal
you know I don't think it's something
that rocks don't eat animals like Amazon
rainforest there's the food chain there
that it's it's isolated from us what do
you call it it's it's self-contained
yeah it's on its own doing its own thing
food chain dies out
correct it's weird that no one ever
talks about parallel food chains I'm
sure many ecologists and such kind of
are aware of in parallel food chains but
whenever people talk about the food
chain they talk about the food chain
yeah like there's only one and and we're
at the top yeah in our food team but
there's any there were how do you know
where well just without going too far I
mean lions they kill zebras or buffalo
you know or wildebeest out there in the
Serengeti or wherever in Africa you know
we don't we don't need any of those at
least most humans don't maybe some
something you know local guy eats at
relying meat or elephant meat or
whatever yeah but we you know in general
there's no market for that and humans
don't eat lions the human don't eat
zebras or buffalo you know those animals
are for tourism not to be killed them
for eating you know we cows we sheep
we'd other stuff you know we don't eat
those animals and so that's our parallel
food chain you know they they do their
own thing yeah it's like we we just go
with our cameras and watch them and in
the Jeep's yes weird to talk about these
multiple what he calls sequence food
chains you know talking about geological
times yeah food chains the Cretaceous
food chain the Jurassic flaking and why
they die is they die all all on their
own
and then when they died they leave room
for the next guys who died on their own
and we don't and we don't need asteroids
we don't need debris cone and every
single time you know our volcanic
eruptions or supernova
raise you know it's happened so
frequently the next plan for the next
food chain well all I can tell you Dan
is the fun I know we already know that
no no let me let me give you a guest
this is my guest no don't don't some
people say you know I'm a I'm a straw
leader I'm a lousy astrologer so don't
believe whatever I say yeah I don't
believe what I say next okay but this is
what I'm this is what I'm gonna propose
I'm gonna say that let's assume humans
die we're gonna take I'm sure most of
the mammals without it's gonna be the
end of the mammals and we're gonna kill
so many of them to eat at the last
moment that whichever one survives will
probably not go on for very long so if
there's a rabbit out there a fox out
there he wants to restart the Adam and
Eve in their world again you know those
animals are dead as well you know in the
long run and so I think all mammals will
disappear most of them at leaves I don't
know if any of them will remain and some
of that is due to the fact that much of
the plants that they eat are the ones we
put out there you know we feed the cows
we allow certain things to grow that
these animals don't eat and among the
things that they don't eat they don't
eat firms I don't know if you know but
ferns are poisonous
they were probably for the dinosaurs as
well and and for sure it was a weed
these animals ate cycas they grew with
the conifers we grew with the
angiosperms but the angiosperms have
good and bad angiosperms you know I mean
I know because I do a lot of planting
and you know you can't you can eat
tomato and you can eat bananas and you
can eat apples those are the fruits you
can eat lettuce you can eat corn wheat
but we don't eat grass and it turns out
that corn and wheat are grasses but
there are different kind of grasses but
we don't eat the grass you know the one
you mow every morning we don't eat those
and there's a lot of stuff that we don't
need out there there are weeds we call
them weeds in fact I have to kill the
weeds before I can plant got to turn
over the land and I'll do all these
things I've got a babysit the crops
because otherwise they don't grow
weeds take over and the reason the weeds
take over is the weeds have been
fighting man for thousands of years you
know we've been killing weeds and
growing what we want and the weeds just
come back with it's like when you try to
fight you know bacteria in your body you
take an antibiotic right and you kill
the bacteria okay you get rid of it but
next time he comes he comes you know
those that survived they they kind of
mutate they create a more formidable
enemy and now you got to create a new
antibiotic to kill that and that's the
same thing with plants you know they
just come back with weeds especially
they come back stronger than ever
fighting against humans and so now we
die right and all the mammals die or
most of the animals diet have mammals
die the weeds take over but what weeds
certainly it's not gonna be the lettuce
that are gonna take over the tomatoes
they're not gonna take over what's gonna
take over all these stinking weeds that
I have to fight with every day those are
gonna take over the land and whatever
little animal especially some insect
that grew eating those eating those
things they got used to those plans that
carved a niche in those weeds I think
those are the ones that have a good
chance of survival now people say the
cockroach is gonna survive I don't know
because the cockroach is a domestic
animal he's a domesticated animal he's a
pet you know pets are not gonna survive
now maybe I don't know maybe the
cockroach will survive I don't know but
I think that well but see the cockroach
likes things that humans like that's
what you find him in the kitchen you
know you you throw a crumb of bread or
whatever you know or whatever you throw
down there there the cockroach will eat
it but the cockroach as far as I know
doesn't eat weeds and if weeds is
anything does no that's not true it's
not true I know for a fact there are
some insects out there that do eat weeds
that we that nobody likes and I think
those animals you know they're in a
different world during a different food
chain and and when we die and all the
mammals die and all the corn
we'd and all the stuff that we died
because nobody will take care of them
and what grows is now all the weeds they
take over the land who's gonna grow with
them who's gonna carbonaceous in them
will those animals that survived who
will be those animals that survived will
be probably those insects that have
forged a relationship with the incoming
weeds and again that will be a new
category of angiosperms some of these
don't even have flowers but I guess
they're considered angiosperms or
flowering plants they have seeds but
it's probably gonna be like what
happened in the old days you had ferns
and you had seed ferns and there were
two different towns somewhere grew in a
different way
you know they grew through spores ferns
in general Grocery spores but these were
seed ferns that don't exist in we don't
have anymore seed firms on planet earth
anymore they died at the Triassic that
was the last and I think they lasted
until the Cretaceous but after that
there were no more seed ferns what
continued were ferns the the old regime
which was based on spores and they
became a smaller portion of the plants
out there in in the world today ferns
you know our small portion of the
vegetation on earth so are the conifers
for that matter you know how many cycads
are there I think there's only two or
three varieties ginkgos there's only one
or two you know these plants used to
cover the land and we forget this that
Jurassic was the age of psyche at some
ginkgos of Bennett details and other
plants that are no longer around and you
know when that whole vegetation
disappeared that's when you know the
dinos disappeared like big bird the
birds I doubt will take over especially
keep in mind one thing there's copes law
known as copse law I don't know why they
named it after Koch because I think he
had very little to do with it but copes
law says that animals grow bigger over
time they essentially the most famous
case in where they got this idea is
Dimetrodon Dimetrodon started around 200
in I'm sorry about 290 million years ago
and lasted to about 270 million years
they lasted like 20 million years and
they were one of the dominant in fact
they were the dominant animal on land in
their region and this animal started a
you know the first skeletons we find
were about a metre and a half and they
grew to three metres long eventually
over the millions of years they
eventually became larger larger and
larger and this is an arms race that you
know the Dimetrodon has to fight it
consider an edifice Auris it thatis ours
is another animal which Dimetrodon
apparently hunted and it's also a big
animal and this guy became bigger this
guy had to become bigger in order to
hunt him and so you know there was this
arms race and that's what drives cokes
law animals over time become bigger
dinosaurs were not originally as big as
t-rex those were the last big ones
who are the last ones of the Jurassic
the long next the big monsters that you
know the Apatosaurus or whatever these
were a hundred tons and a hundred year
old that's what they say because that's
how much it takes to grow such an animal
a hundred years old and a hundred tons
this is a monster animal and it's always
at the end that all these animals that
you find these animal at the end of a
mass extinctions always the big animals
that die always now that's a smart
asteroid that can do that okay so so if
so Birds I don't think so
remember that you know you have the
Quetzalcoatl he was the flying reptile
the the monster at the end of the
Cretaceous he died why because he was
big but not only because he was big he
was old he was an old species old
species die you know mother nature kills
the old species in a mass extinction not
the new ones so it's a chronological
extinction the old animals the old order
gets washed away they're the dominant
animals what continues are the tiny
little animals you know in this case our
mammal
ancestors they took over the land by old
species you mean a species that's been
around for a while like for example
humans what do you mean do you mean we
got a cook we gotta be careful
talk about humans ok yeah yeah let me
clarify that old species I mean the
following you know the dinosaurs took
over the land they didn't start existing
for the first time but they took over
the land in the Jurassic 200 million
years ago roughly ok
until then the arcus ours had grooved
the land they were the big guys and the
dinosaurs were the little guys they had
to hide or they were gonna be eaten so
they had to worry about you know the the
arcus are getting a hold of that when
the Argos ours went away I guess because
like rhodium disappeared in their whole
system collapse now the dinosaurs took
over what did they date the the rubbish
that the arcus ours couldn't eat which
was the cycads they're already yeah they
were already but now these plants grew
and they took over the land they kicked
aside all the ferns and and they took
over the land the Jurassic is the age of
sight cats and so now the cycads covered
the land what continues all the
dinosaurs they start growing in
relationship to the site cats and the
cycads
I think it's more the cycads than the
sight cast personally I think they like
the cycad yo it's a lot better because
they were more popular in those days
well to make a long story short you know
this psycho continued in the Cretaceous
again what continues are the dinosaurs
but a different kind of dinosaur and we
have different kinds of plants again
conifers but the site cycads and uh
William Sonja's Andy Bennett details all
these started dining out what continues
now are you know they these plants still
continue but their forests are shrinking
their jungles are sinking shrinking and
what replaces them are the
Rock area the we don't need the whole
[Music]
species
okay the old specie again these these
animals start out these animals start
out a long time ago talking about maybe
135 million years ago it's considered
the beginning of the Cretaceous and you
got until the 65 million years ago you
got 70 million years ago 70 million
years of the distance of the news
appears only in the last 2 million years
of the Cretaceous there were no T Rexes
throughout the Cretaceous there's no
such thing it's it's like a curve and
you can see this peeking out at the end
at the last 2 million years that's when
the big guys the theropods you know they
come out you know from hiding that's
when they show up in the rock the last
species aren't you calling it all
because if you look at the history of
all these the hadrosaurs and the and
Killa SARS
there was all these different dinosaurs
going throughout the land and they
existed even before t-rex theater I just
said oh this is a great source of food
and they started eating them right but
before that all these animals were still
there and you see an evolution of the
hydras our specialty over millions of
years and these animals also they
started being small they look like
llamas you would say it's the camel
version of the of the Dinosaur World
something like that okay so these
animals start growing what since way
back when they were small and we always
see that as you go into the past you see
that all these animals are smaller and
as you look into layer rock you find
bigger and bigger skeletons until you
reach the end where they're all monsters
and we all remember the monsters the
ones from Jurassic Barbies that oh
that's that's great but that's not how
it was throughout the Cretaceous and so
that so the size of animals is the
history of life on Earth
sense you know it gives you what a
histogram of what's happening to the
animal world in relationship to the
plant world because of the plants expand
the animals also expand there's also an
arms race between carnivore and
herbivores all that drives this whole
thing drives cokes law where they all
become bigger and bigger towards the end
but by the time they're big it means
they've been around at least their
dynasty has been around for millions of
years how do you know I mean we know
when well again you don't find because
Big T Rexes before two million years two
million years before the end of the
crypto are talking about evolution the
beginning of the species well the first
the first thing you got to think is that
you know God does not create the t-rex
with his magic wand from day one and
says okay today I'm gonna create a t-rex
now obviously this guy had some
ancestors and it took at least thousands
if not millions of years to forge this
animal and you know so we go in the
record and we don't find a big t-rex
like the one that succumbed at the end
of the Cretaceous we find maybe smaller
animals and sometimes these they confuse
them because we don't know for sure but
we look at a skeleton we find maybe five
billion years before the Cretaceous and
we say well here's the smaller dinosaur
we'll call it a velociraptor
you know Velociraptor and and it turns
out that maybe that was the ancestor of
the t-rex for all we know you know I
mean these guys do their analysis and
say well no this was a different animal
and and he was around and he was a
predator and all this and that you know
but it could be a news but it could be
that it's one of the ancestor maybe
that's where the t-rex came out of you
know and I can't say that the
Velociraptor is is where where t-rex
came from I'm just giving you an example
here I'm just saying that there must
have been some animal that preceded
Teeter Teeter ribs didn't just come out
of the magic wand
yeah and so you know what I'm saying is
you will have a history of the life of
an atom or at least you can imagine it
that you know there must have been some
kind of sequence that led to that animal
he's got to have a history yeah okay
what why are humans going to die out
prematurely compared to a dinosaurs you
seem like a young species are we are we
wise beyond her years I like that
question because people have a wrong
idea of what old means okay yeah I'm 65
going on 66 this year so I'm old but but
we're not talking about individual we're
talking about species collective can we
talk about uh the oldest the other
species doesn't does a species get old
ancient or whatever any answers yes
but it doesn't matter how many times the
earth goes around the Sun which is what
we always think about you know what we
think I'm how many candles are on the
birthday cake and that's not what we're
talking about mother nature does open us
in a different way Dimetrodon lasted
twenty million years the this lineage
this dynasty first smaller and then
eventually bigger until the 3-meter
Dimetrodon like was Angelo Angelo
diametre well one of the categories I
can't remember the name now but one of
the categories you know lasted at the
end of the conversion which is about 270
million years ago middle of the Permian
this guy was three meters long okay and
the question is how did this animal live
20 million years this dynasty and the
dinosaurs or the t-rex is only lived two
million years and you look at the
tearing say oh that this guy is much
more mightier than that Dimetrodon and
you only live two million years and this
guy lived ten times as much and now we
only live two hundred thousand years and
now we're going extinct and you say hold
it we're smarter than the theory we
could have you know tied terraces around
a little finger we would have put them
in zoos and and how come how can we live
ten times less than t-rex is there what
the question itself because you're
essentially saying the older species
talking about not not age but um but in
history the further back in history you
go the longer species live then we had T
Rex's head shorter lifespans and again
before them we have shorter life species
I'll give you a better example sixteen
is like whatever comes after us is just
gonna live like ten years mammals lived
if we die now mammals have will have
lived only 65 million years ago and I
don't mean live I mean that they were
dominant on the planet yes sixty-five
million years the t-rex inaptitude that
dinosaurs were dominant the second half
I mean we got to distinguish them the
dinosaurs that came in the Cretaceous
from those that came in the Jurassic
but those live you know 70 million years
and before that we had the diner the
other dinosaur they lived almost uh you
know 75 million years maybe something
like that before then you had the
Permian and I'm sorry Triassic and they
lived almost you know over 50 million
years and you say you know okay so where
do these animals live so long and I'm
saying and I'm saying it's got to do
with this it's more complex than this by
the way but I'm just gonna simplify it
okay and I'm just gonna say that the
dumber and animal is the longer he lives
oh that's great that summarizes my my
general thought okay what am i referring
to I'm saying that the longer an animal
takes to fight disease the longer it
takes for him to clean
his genetic diversity okay it takes
longer for an animal to for any species
order to fight against the disease if a
lot of them die and die and die and die
there are healthy species okay because
they're killed and they have to restart
the process all over again they never
get to they never get to they always get
the same diseases because the diseases
don't have to mutate because the disease
can still kill them or or do have caused
havoc among you can call it like a
symbiosis in a sense that the animals to
match the current disease so their birth
and death rate is kind of stable in that
sense yeah disease keeps them down
because they have an adaptive population
pyramid remains she's a healthy all
along many things die very young so by
default there's a lot more young than
old but what did we do what did humans
ooh we're smart
I can't tell you exactly all the details
of each species all I can say and that's
why I like that's why I like that human
example because it just puts it in in
light and makes you think and again this
is nothing to make you believe it just
to make you think what's going through
my mind so that you understand what
process I'm proposing I'm saying that
hear me turn say hey let's do it with
injections or work better living
conditions or whatever we did you know
we put fire so so we killed all the
bacteria before we ate the meat and all
these kinds of things that we
implemented well that mean that maybe we
cheated Mother Nature's she says okay no
problem just make you live a shorter
life that's it it's like what happened
to Achilles I called it the Achilles
Singh syndrome Achilles Achilles was
offered two things either a long life
with no glory you know just a boring
life or a short life with a lot of lots
of glory
and apparently he either he chose or the
gods chose Wharram he chose the short
life with glorious yeah and and so
that's what happened to us we chose a
short life with glory and we have
intelligence we have technology we are
the kings of the planet we are so
arrogant we think we're gonna go to
other planets and live forever and who
knows what and we're not even the
gardener of Eden we are just another
animal we don't realize that we think
we're we're special
and we're not special no we're not we
leave we're not we burn twice as hot and
we we reproduce a billion people large
animals you know we're all our gentlemen
[Music]
more or less like that and we are a star
that shines twice as bright as other
mammals and we lived half as long yeah
we are specially shiny we are special in
the sense that that yeah we have
intelligence actually taken that
algorithm to its extreme what he gets
any more extreme than that but but short
is speech the species or species has
lived the shortest a species possibly
can but we we we rocked we lived a great
life you know we live a great life
because we have intelligence and we have
this awareness but that same
intelligence is accelerating our demise
what does that mean specifically human
versus disease well what I'm saying is
that we we we figured out real quick
well not quick but in last two hundred
years we are three hundred maybe we
figured out how to fight disease which
was our biggest killer
the biggest killer weren't Wars the
biggest killer were disease the most
important one was smallpox that's what
killed most humans at least in the last
thousand years smallpox and we also had
you know bouts of black plague you know
and those killed lots of people millions
of people one third of the population of
Europe is said anywhere from one third
of one half died in 1350 to in those
year 1314
to 1352 14th century during the Black
Plague in Europe not to mention those
that died in China where the Black
Plague allegedly came from you know
Black Plague was a big problem bubonic
plague you know it was a big million
yeah you're talking about millions of
people they had no workers talk about
today we we have we were taking workers
out those days they had no one to plow
the fields because everybody was dead
yeah so you know it was disease that
killed us and what we did was we fought
disease and we said ah we're smart we
can fight disease and mother nature just
stands there laughing said oh the faster
you fight disease the sooner you will be
your extinction
the less you know well because what kept
us from multiplying disease what do you
mean no no no we why are we eight
billion people today we're eight billion
people today because we we are eight
what we don't die of disease the old
days everybody died no disease you're
talking about the multiplied the state
alive we always multiplying yeah right
right absolutely right
smart kid I've got you know that's but
yeah so we have more people alive they
should be dead correct we should have
all been dead you know the lots of
people who should have died today but we
don't die anymore we don't die a disease
of contagious diseases immediately when
there's an outbreak the doctors are in
there you know with injections or better
living conditions or sanitary measures
and immediately you know we we overruled
the disease we don't die of disease
today today we die of age-related
diseases they're all genetic diseases in
other words what do we die heart disease
we die of old age we call it you know
but it's what is old age diabetes what
I've got I mean I know what I'm gonna
die of arthritis you know those are kind
of like just because we're hitting the
limits of how long cells the other thing
right they say you can't really fight
well you can I mean we we might invent
something that fights genetics somehow
but I don't know what they're gonna
convert me into if they keep injecting
me stuff against genetic problems you
know I might turn into a terrorist Ella
Mears can but a more normal talk there's
only so many times a cell can split yeah
there's only so many times we can renew
our body and there's kind of nothing
that that's that's a separate issue
dying of old age then catching smallpox
yeah not being able to basically dying
before is your time that's what smallpox
and a flick limit it's called the the
the fact that cells can Moulton split
sometimes in our case at 60 times that's
called the hayflick living bigger the
animal the higher the hayflick limit
that's also interesting it's a in
relationship with copes law okay but to
that point it's that anytime we talk
about illness uh-huh we're talking about
that which will kill you before your
time before your lifespan before your
cells split as many times they could
that's not really that's just that's
just your time is up before the time
that mother nature promised you imagine
us be 80 years and she kills me at the
age of 50 yeah damn it you you are a lot
of 80 maximum nothing but you've got
smallpox and you couldn't handle it and
you can have an action you could be
robbed and killed you know there's so
many things that can get in the way of
you're alive you thought you were gonna
live to the age of 80 you die at the age
of 20 you know so that happens all the
time but a statistically you know we're
living too long ages we're living now
the ages of 70 75 80 I don't know what
the world average is but it's getting
close to 70
yeah it's getting up there and you know
you got countries like Japan that the
average is 80 you know the the lifespan
is guaranteed to be like 80 years old
we're just living two great old ages
worldwide the average life expectancy
seven five years okay it's around 70
yeah and Japan has like 80 and it's the
older countries that have like 70 or 60
maybe you go to Africa or to South
America and you'll find worse living
conditions so people die more often they
don't have medical attention so they die
more often and that throws the numbers
down otherwise you know humans can live
maybe anywhere between 70 and 100 years
old
you know most humans if unless you know
some accident or something gets you and
that's simply you know shows you that
you know we we live a long time because
that took a long time to develop that's
part of our evolution but what does that
mean that means also we're at the end of
the line because now that also shifts
the reproductive range downwards well we
live longer we the reproductive age
bracket still remains low in comparison
I mean the old days it used to be that
girls reproduce at the age of 15 maybe I
don't know any average you could say and
everybody that at the age of 30 35 40
because of wars disease or whatever yeah
and so that was a it was a very low
average and so the reproductive age was
a big portion of that of your life today
in the reproductive age bracket is a
small portion you know that we actually
use v it used to be a half yeah and now
we live to the age of 80 but we produced
and we don't even reproduce at the age
of 15 anymore now we do it from 30 to 35
and it's a very short bracket because we
only have one kid you know it's or not
it and so on so does bacteria evolve at
an amazing rate compared to animals yeah
I mean back to you uh expands for
example you put a piece of bread you can
do this at home you put up
bread it'll turn green after a couple
days and you know bacteria will multiply
but again what holds it in is the what
is it the density dependent birth rates
at some point he's talking about evolved
evolution does bacteria evolve
Oh mutation you fast kill but it's a
molecule that's formed on the base of
DNA and it has the ability of making
copies of itself reproduces itself it's
like one of those BOTS that they call
that you gets into your body goes into
the cell and makes copies of itself and
you know one of those is the polio virus
it's a virus okay the molecule and
there's been a mutation of these viruses
in the last 50 or 60 years and the new
strain is deadly yeah mutation in the
sense that it's almost the same molecule
but it changes some part of it and so
now whatever anti virus you had before
or whatever measures you took against it
is no longer effective now you have to
develop a new one and and this developed
only in the last 50 60 years and again
the way bacteria and viruses do it is
you know you you you take an antibiotic
and it kills you know most of the
bacteria in your body but you know those
few that survived that have some natural
defense against whatever you used
against them
those are formidable because now those
reproduce that antibiotic didn't kill
those and I have to develop a new end of
body and so with antibiotics we are
triggering the creation of new bacteria
just like geologically in seconds in
microseconds compared you know what it
would take a bacterium millions of years
to evolve is now evolving in one
two years maybe months who knows yeah
same thing we fight against the weeds
and the weeds develop you know ways a
fighting man you know we we throw
chemicals Adam we hit you know I know
for a fact I hit him with a shovel i I
do everything to the weeds and they come
back stronger every time and I have to
fight against the weeds and they grow so
fast that it's unbelievable and here I
have my little tomato you know I'm on
life support you know with the tube in
their mouth trying to make grow a little
tomato out there in a field with all
these weeds around it and that's the
same thing happens with bacteria
bacteria we are fighting against them
every day we take it for granted that
we're developing antibiotics but what
are we doing we're just creating new
strains of bacteria we can't get rid of
the bacteria all we do is create new new
varieties now we we are creating what is
it called niches for them to to exploit
[Laughter]
ok the age of humanity again I think
humans first of all we have to consider
that you know we have more than 200,000
years of life our specific species our
branch only 200,000 years but we come
from you know probably some African
ancestor more than likely and that guy
came from you know what was a and that
guy came from Homo erectus ok homo
rhodesiensis is considered our ancestry
he's from Rhodesia what used to be
Rhodesia today's called Zimbabwe and
homo rhodesiensis they found a guy there
that says well this is very likely our
ancestor and assuming if we concede that
that guy came from homo erectus because
there was no other homo in in Africa and
before that and so assuming that lineage
is correct that dynasty you know we we
come from way back when I'm from before
then we can have Homo habilis
he came before Homo erectus and again
these are categories that they look in
the rock and that's the best we can come
out with with what little evidence we
have that's the general picture and
again some people lots of people don't
believe in that and that's that's fine
but I think there's been an evolution of
humans from some kind of ancestor and if
you keep going back you know at some
point we split from the chimps from the
gorillas and so on down the line so and
so on you call it well again when did
the monkeys appear you know the ape see
you know and before then you know you
even have prior animals and you know I
always say that all of us all of us all
animals alive today can trace their
lineage all the way to the Cambrian
hopefully listen to what I'm saying we
can all trace our lineage to the
Cambrian there was some kind of animal
out there waiting in the wings that
became us eventually otherwise you know
how would you justify it you know you if
you keep going back you should find some
kind of animal from which the other
animal came and so I'm down the line and
and we probably you know came from
monkeys yeah and then what did the
monkey come from well he came from some
kind of Lamoure or some other tree
dwelling animal and where that guy come
from and that guy come probably came
from purgatory as' little rat like guy
who lived in Cretaceous and that guy and
you can take that going back and back
and back and we should be able to trace
our lineage all the way to the Cambrian
and you know that's why they call these
synapses or mammal-like reptiles why
because they say that we descend from
them and you know here the therapsids
they died at the end of the Permian 252
million years ago and they say you know
we came from those guys because they had
mammalian characteristics and where else
could we have inherited the mam
part of those mammal-like reptiles and
where did they come from well hopefully
for some animal in the Carboniferous and
those from the previous from the
Devonian and silurian and Ordovician and
we take it all the way to the Cambrian
so hopefully every animal alive today
can trace his lineage all the way to
grandpappy you know five hundred million
years ago no because I think when we
talk about species I think we're talking
about carving niches and that's when a
species kind of specializes and when he
specializes in food and living
conditions in habitats and different
things you know he loses track of who
his ancestor was so even though we might
have some animal almost for sure that
gave origin to the human lineage all the
way to the Cambrian you know this is the
Adam and Eve you know since we carved
our own niche I don't know maybe two
hundred thousand years ago well then we
became a separate species in that sense
and I think you have to consider again
one thing I was gonna cover today was
you know what is the species and a
species is that which can interbreed
successfully and I'm sure we could not
endure breed successfully with you know
with chimp six million years ago if
today we had sex with a chimp for sure
we can't have kids with him and so you
know in that sense we're a separate
species we developed differently and we
can only interbreed with our own kind
where we're we can't interbreed with any
other type of animal on earth today it's
we're the last branch of the hominids
and hominins so you'd say it's safe to
say that one species once the species
carves out a specific niche that's when
their cost starts taking
yeah yeah essentially that's very
interesting yeah at that point your your
clock is starting that's when you're
born
well not born with this you are born I
mean a species is born at that point
time and now that animal that species
never gonna intermarry with another
species ever again that's the that's the
they start their last Trek on earth and
we started that Trek maybe maybe this is
just a ballpark figure anywhere between
200 300 thousand years ago so if that's
the case you know we've been around
maybe anywhere from 200 right
typical humans are kind anyway 200 to
300 thousand years ago what do I mean by
that I mean that if if we could go back
in time or bring back a guy from 200 to
300 thousand years ago we could still
have offspring with that person when
that's individual we're still
genetically that close that we can still
have maybe some some hybrid that is a
little sterile but we could probably
have sex and children with that
individual but if you take it farther
back you know you're guaranteed not to
have children because the guy was so
different than us so our ancestor who
was maybe 400 500 thousand years ago we
almost certainly could not interbreed
with that person today does this is the
niche carving out clocks the clock take
starter thing basically when a species
carves out its own Anish uh-huh that's
when as clock starts ticking when we're
talking about the age of its species is
that does that have to do with the fact
that when a species carves out a niche
it's special is DNA kind of specializes
itself far more specifically kind of
away from everyone else to film that
deviation is what kind of marks this
characteristic of species clock starting
to take or it's it's a new species when
it carves out a niche yeah I cover that
in quite a bit of detail in my last book
and the Neanderthal book and I because
you know one of the things you got to
look at is how is the species born you
know how is it species well before you
can talk about its death
please tell me how it was born and and
so you have a couple things here first
it's nice to know when it was born and
if possible and it died and in between
there's got to be a point where it was
at its peak population so you got a
triangle this is what I do this is my
train of thought okay you got birth you
got death and those were low points in
population and in between somewhere in
between there's gotta be we got a
triangle right there's gotta be a high
point where this animal had the most
population this was a golden age for
some reason okay and so you know you get
a triangle and then you got to make that
curve you know somehow you got to fit
the curve as best as possible and that's
how you can tell you know how long a
species lived and you can almost predict
when it's gonna die because it's gonna
once it Peaks all you can do is start
going downwards yeah no yeah no no what
I'm saying is once you determine that
curve that's the same curve for all
species so even species that haven't
died you can say I know this one's gonna
die because all you got to do is fit the
curve on them okay so I think all
animals pretty much follow this this
curve it's called it's called the
s-curve but I call it a little more than
an s-curve because they always have the
S curve at the top and I'm saying that
goes down at the end so it goes like
this and then go and they forget that
last part the extinction yeah yeah yeah
and so you know I'm saying that at some
point when we became a species because
we did so in isolation and we carved a
niche in some kind of habitat and when
we did that what happened was you know
we specialized and by special and
specializing means many things here and
yeah it's a it's a long story to tell
you what my thought on genetics is how
genetics created that individual and how
that individual selectively not because
they selected but because Mother Nature
selected for them started using
different genes for different purposes
the ground rules for evolution yeah yeah
and it's it has to do with the origin of
species and and you know there's been
quite a bit of study at the beginning of
the 20th century which is interesting to
look at because it shows you you know
what some of the tests they've run some
of the experiments they run and how they
interpret those experiments it's very
interesting and what you will find is
that or at least what I found that's my
interpretation is that you know an
animal that goes into isolation from the
mother 3 here you have a branch and they
go into a new habitat new new region or
whatever they get isolated from the from
the trunk and what they do is now they
start using different genes in their
body to adapt to the new environment and
it's those genes that are gonna make it
into a new species over the centuries
they don't use correct
genes you have
I mean imagine mentioned the
Neanderthals they they went into the
Arctic region and be in you know they
didn't go there they descended from
Heidelberg more than likely and hi there
goes descended from the homo erectus
that went into that region these guys
had no clothes and so this monkey goes
out there and he adapts to freezing
weathers to glacier weathers and he
passes that on to you know the who ever
lived
800,000 years ago like in Pakefield in
England or or Happisburgh you know
700,000 years ago 800,000 years ago the
whoever was there you know certainly did
not have clothes and so they had to use
genes that to combat the cold and so
they develop and you just said they
don't use blue jeans yeah they didn't
have blue they had green jeans or
something you know but the point is you
know these guys
we developed or triggered new genes to
help them fight the environment and some
of the ones that they did not need were
lost and so they became a new species
from them descended to hide their births
from them descended the Neanderthals and
of course they were a different species
you know after hundred thousands of
years and when we went up there you know
I don't think I don't think we ever saw
Nanda Thal but assuming we did we were
part of their food we became that day
you know that was our last day but when
they were gone you know we could go in
there but what did we we didn't have the
the defenses for the cold so we invented
clothes and covered ourselves come to
our shame this be okay we'll see you
tomorrow same time same station we'll
continue with a subject probably end at
this tomorrow okay okay I have to change
the title we'll see you tomorrow bye-bye